the troubles did see a terrible
extensive period of violence that
claimed the lives of some three and a
half thousand people
left up to 40 000 people injured and
caused untold damage to all aspects of
society in northern ireland
the belfast good friday agreement in
1998 sought to move northern ireland
forward
setting a bold and a visionary path that
would guide all the people of northern
ireland towards a shared
stable peaceful and prosperous future
it is wonderful to mark in this
centenary year just in fact just how far
northern ireland has come while north
london is undoubtedly today
a fantastic place to live and to work
and visit
the unresolved legacy of the troubles
remains it continues to
impact and permeate society in northern
ireland
the past is a constant shadow over those
who directly experience the horrors of
those times
and also over those who did not but who
now live with the trauma
of previous generations it is clear that
the current system for dealing with the
legacy of the troubles
is not working it is now a difficult
in fact a painful truth that the focus
on criminal investigations
is increasingly unlikely to deliver
successful criminal justice outcomes
but all the while it continues to divide
communities
and it fails to obtain answers for a
majority of victims
and families this is borne out in the
figures
the police service of northern ireland
are currently considering almost twelve
hundred cases which represents just a
fraction of the three and a half
thousand deaths and wider cases
these would take over twenty years to
investigate
more than two-thirds of troubles-related
deaths occurred over 40 years ago
and it is increasingly difficult for the
courts to provide families
with the answers they are seeking if we
fail
to act now to properly address
acknowledge
and account for the legacy of the
troubles we will be condemning current
and future generations to yet further
division
preventing reconciliation at both the
individual and societal level
mr speaker that is why i am today laying
before this house
and publishing a paper that proposes a
series of measures
to address the legacy of the past in
northern ireland
these proposals are being considered as
part of an ongoing and an important
engagement process
which i announced alongside the irish
government at the british irish
intergovernmental conference
last month i set out in the framework
which we published at the same time this
engagement process is committed to
involving not just the uk and irish
governments in the northern
parties but also those directly affected
by the troubles and experts and members
and committees
of this house and the other place the
objective of this engagement
is to deal with legacy issues in a way
that supports information recovery and
reconciliation
complies fully with international human
rights obligations
and responds to the needs of individual
victims and survivors
as well as society as a whole
this is a hugely difficult and complex
issue and many have strongly held and
divergent views on how to move forward
but we can all agree that this i hope we
can all agree that this is an issue
that is of the utmost importance to the
people of northern ireland and beyond
it is critical that all involved
continue to engage in a spirit of
collaboration in order to deliver
practical solutions on this most
sensitive of issues
this government reaffirms its commitment
to intensive engagement in this spirit
and we are committed to introducing
legislation by the end of this autumn
the measures set out in the paper will
include three
key proposals firstly a new independent
body
that will focus on the recovery and
provision of information about troubles
related deaths and most serious injuries
this body will be focused on helping
families to find out the truth
of what's happened to their loved ones
where families do not want the past rate
over again
they would be able to make this clear
but those families for those families
that want to get answers
the body will have the full powers to
seek access to information
and find out what's happened a package
of measures
will also include a major oral history
initiative consistent with what was
included in the storm and house
agreement
this initiative would create
opportunities for people from all
backgrounds
to share their experiences and
perspectives related to the troubles
and crucially to learn about those of
others
balance and sensitivity would be of
central importance
and a concerted effort would be made to
engage with those whose voices may not
have been heard previously
and thirdly a statute of limitations to
apply equally to all troubles related
incidents
we know that the prospect of the end of
criminal prosecutions will be difficult
for some to accept
and this is not a position that we take
lightly
but we've come to the view that this is
the best and only way
to facilitate an effective information
retrieval and provision process
and the best way to help northern
ireland move further along the road
to reconciliation it is in reality a
painful recognition
of the very reality of where we are
and as i say these issues are complex
and they are sensitive
that is why they remain unresolved 23
years after the belfast good friday
agreement
and we also understand the importance of
the stomach house agreement remain
committed
to its key principles which this paper
will outline and cover
in particular we acknowledge that any
proposal that moves away from criminal
justice outcomes
would be a very significant step that
will be extremely difficult for some
families to accept
the belfast good friday agreement was a
bold step
one to address the past and there have
been other such bold steps such as the
decommissioning of weapons and the
limiting of sentences
all those years ago to two years however
it is increasingly clear to us
that the ongoing retributive criminal
justice processes
are far from helping in fact impeding
the successful delivery
of information recovery mediation and
reconciliation
that could provide a sense of
restorative justice for many more
families
than is commonly the case the government
is committed to doing all in its power
to ensure that families from across the
united kingdom do not continue to be let
down by a process
which leads only to pain suffering and
disappointment
for the vast majority as part of this
we will deliver on our commitment to
veterans who served in northern ireland
we will provide certainty to former
members of the security forces
many of whom remain fearful of the
prospect of being the subject
of ongoing investigations that will hang
over them for years to come
even though the vast majority acted in
accordance with the law
are often a great personal risk
we are also unequivocal in our
commitment to delivering for victims and
survivors
time is crucial and as it moves on we
risk the very real possibility that we
will lose any chance to get the vital
information that families want
and need they have waited long enough
and a focus on information would offer
the best chance
of giving more families some sense of
justice through acknowledgement
accountability
and restorative means we need to
progress our understanding of the
complexity of the troubles and in doing
so
seek to reconcile society with the past
as we go on to look forward together
this government is determined to address
all aspects of northern ireland's
troubled past
we know from our recent history
particularly with the implementation of
the belfast good friday agreement that
we can achieve more
when we are bold and move forward
together i want us all to continue to
engage on the shape and the detail of
the proposals as we work to address
this issue which is of the utmost
importance to the people of northern
ireland and beyond
finally mr speaker i would just draw the
attention of the house to a quote
from margaret fairless barber i came
across it in reading the report by lord
eames and dennis bradley into northern
ireland's past i think it's just worth
repeating today in this house
to look backward for a while is to
refresh the eye to restore it
and to render it more fit for its prime
function of looking forward
i commend this statement to the house